DUSTIN KIRKLAND: My
name's Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager
at Google, and I'm here
with Maya Kaczorowski, also
a product manager at Google.
And she knows everything
about security--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I certainly
don't know everything
about security.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Enough that we're
going to talk about security.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sounds good.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Especially the
security vulnerabilities space
around Kubernetes.
What interesting vulnerabilities
have you seen recently?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah, in
the last couple of months,
we've had a couple
of interesting vulns.
So let's look at 2019.
There was a RunC vulnerability
earlier this year,
which was, effectively,
a container escaped.
And then more recently,
the Alpine images had a--
newer versions have a
root default password,
which is kind of scary-looking.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And what was
that password, just so we know?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I
think it was just null.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I
think it was null.
I think you're exactly right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah,
which is terrifying.
And then obviously,
we've also had
some additional speculative
execution vulnerabilities
that have been announced.
So lots of things affecting
the kernel and OSs
and the Kubernetes
space recently.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
and what are we learning?
Are we learning
anything from this,
trying to make Kubernetes
and our space better?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I think one
thing we've really realized
is that Kubernetes is actually
really good at managing patches
and vulnerabilities, right?
Kubernetes has a
product security team
that handles
Kubernetes-specific vulns.
And then probably
your cloud provider
is managing a lot of
that stuff for you.
On GCP, we manage
the patches for you,
and you can check out
the security bulletins
to see how you've been patched.
But we're also seeing
a lot of interest
from security
researchers in the space
and seeing what's
going on and can they
exploit these vulnerabilities
in live environments?
So the RunC vuln had
proofs of concept
available within
a matter of days.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And the--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And how
quickly were patches available?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Patches were available--
so it was embargoed, and
at announcement the patches
were available.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK, good, good.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
the Alpine images,
a security researcher recently
found out that 20% of them--
20% of the top Docker Hub images
were using the null password,
which is absolutely terrifying.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Wow.
So that's Kubernetes itself.
What about the applications
inside of Kubernetes?
How are we approaching this in
a modern containerized software
world that--
I don't know, hopefully
is a little bit better
than prior generations
of software?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah,
that's a good point.
I think people just-- they
think of attacks on containers
as being only one category.
But you can split it up between
attacks on the infrastructure,
like towards the Kubernetes
API server, versus attacks
on applications
which just happen
to be running in containers.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
so for applications
that happen to be
running in containers,
we're not seeing
attacks in the wild that
are significantly different
or significantly more common
than you would see in
any other environment.
What's happening is
people are looking--
attackers are lazy, right?
They're looking
for vulnerabilities
that have been
unpatched for years
and seeing if they
can exploit those,
and they don't seem to
care whether or not it's
a containerized application.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Would
it be fair to say
that modern CI/CD and the
way we use that in Kubernetes
should be helping our ability
to patch safely and reliably?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
It should, right.
If you think about
a container, you're
not patching a live container.
You're actually patching a
container that sits in a--
an image that sits in a
registry and then rebuilding
and redeploying that container.
So patching becomes
as easy for you
to implement as your typical--
your normal rollout process.
So you can actually patch
something with the same canary
testing, deployment,
all those tools
that you would use anyway and
make it much safer than you
would otherwise.
What that should mean
in theory, although not
always in practice, is that
you should be able to patch
more often and patch more
easily than you would've
been able to do before.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And do you
think we're seeing that yet?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
I think we are.
I hear of some customers
who are tearing down
their entire environment and
redeploying it every x hours, x
days, for sure.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right,
GKE and security,
what are some of the
things we're doing to push
the envelope in that space?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure, so at
our recent Next conference,
Google Cloud announced
a couple of things.
We have binary
authorization, which
is our way of enforcing
that containers
meet certain
requirements before they
get deployed to production.
CGR vulnerability
scanning, this is
related to what we
were just talking
about around patching
things before they end up
in production so you actually
can apply certain patches.
It lets you scan images
in your repository
for known vulnerabilities.
And we just
announced GKE Sandbox
in beta, which is using Google's
gVisor technology to help you
isolate untrusted code
in your environment
in multi-tenant environments.
And of course, we're
working on more
but I don't have anything
to share right away.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All right.
Maya, thank you very much.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]